Pakistan's prime minister Imran Khan has
asked the president to dissolve
parliament and hold new elections that's
after a motion of no confidence against
him was dismissed without a vote the
deputy speaker declared the move
unconstitutional he said it was part of
what he called a plot by foreign powers
to interfere in Pakistan's Democratic
process the opposition believed that it
had the numbers to oust Khan after
several political allies cited against
him let's go live to Islamabad
al-jazeera's Osama bin Javid is there
what's been the reaction to all of this
Osama
well it is a constitutional crisis that
Pakistan finds itself in right now
opposition members are staging a sit-in
at the National Assembly where this no
confidence motion was thrown out by the
speaker the opposition insisting that it
is unconstitutional and illegal they say
they will elect their own speaker of the
National Assembly because they now have
the majority and according to the norms
and rules of the Constitution and
democracy the Prime Minister should have
vote should have faced a vote of no
confidence rather than running away from
the assembly the prime minister is
saying that this is a matter of national
interest right now Pakistan is facing a
grave threat from outside and that's why
he's asked the president to dissolve the
assemblies all of this uh has bearings
or because of the Constitution of
Pakistan and with this is a former judge
of the high court in Lahore
Abbasi thank you very much for being
with us is this a constitutional crisis
isn't Imran Khan right in saying that he
can just dissolve the assembly days and
things can move forward towards an
election as far as the Constitutional
crisis is concerned that's that's that
is there but in fact what was required
by the Constitution and the law was that
once the vote of no confidence is moved
in the National Assembly the Prime
Minister loses the power to dissolve the
assembly but what has happened uh to
today in the National summary is that
the speaker of the National Assembly has
rejected the the resolution which was
moved against the Prime Minister and he
has a provoked the the assembly now
after that the Prime Minister has
announced that the the I I advise the
president to dissolve the assembly and
in terms of the Constitution if the
Prime Minister advises the president it
is dissolved automatically within 48
hours but what's the legal recourse that
is available to the opposition because
they say that they are going to go to
the Supreme Court the only legally
courts available to the to the
opposition is to approach the Supreme
Court of Pakistan and to file a petition
against the the act of the speaker and
the orders of the prime minister
Pakistan to dissolve the assemblies and
they are going to do that and do you
think that it is or if the assemblies
are dissolved things are going to move
forward or the Supreme Court can hold
this decision illegal and they will be
back to a new confidence yes of course
the Supreme Court has got all the powers
and reconstruction article 184 to
declare all the acts of the of the of
the speaker and the Prime Minister and
the act of dissolution of Nissan
National Assembly as illegal and
unconstitutional and it has been
happening in the history of Pakistan
when the general haq he dissolved the
assemblies it was the The Other Side
went to the Supreme Court and Supreme
Court said that this act of the
president was illegal but at that point
of time it was observed that since the
elections have been announced therefore
it will be advisable to go on for the
fresh elections Mr bossy thank you very
much there you go that's the update uh
at the legal view on where we are
constitutionally in Pakistan as this
crisis unfold it's a rapidly moving
story in the last few minutes we've
heard from the state Minister for
information saying elections will be
held in 90 days the minister for
information who also holds the portfolio
of the law Minister says that the the
cabinet of prime minister Imran Khan has
also been dissolved and he is going to
continue to serve as the prime minister
of Pakistan so it is a a movie it's
moving story which is going to be very
critical at least for today because it
is the last day according to the
Constitution to hold this vote of no
confidence against the Prime Minister
we've heard from the leader of the
opposition and the chairman of the
Pakistan People's Party saying they are
going to move the Supreme Court this
being a Sunday it is likely that that is
going to happen on a Monday but in in if
the Supreme Court decides in their favor
if the Supreme Court decides that the
decision of the Deputy speaker of
parliament was illegal then they will
have to go back to square one and hold
vote of no confidence not just here is
Osama Bin Javad reporting live there
from Islamabad Osama many thanks